vous refusez d'être assigné à un camp
mais fort cette constater que depuis
quelques années vous vous battez
d’arrache-pied pour que les violences
faites aux femmes soient à la fois
reconnues et si possible condamnés et
oui c'était un métier avocat qui suit le
mouvement de la société et mis tout a
quand même été un mouvement qui a
emporté et qui continue d'emporter la
société et je crois que c'est l'apanage
de l'avocat d'être aux côtés de ceux ou
celles en l'occurrence celles qui qui se
battent et donc le cabinet c'est aussi
rempli de femmes qui sont venus stockées
à la porte alors justement votre cabinet
100% féminin un quatuor d'associé toute
ancienne secrétaire de la Conférence du
stage autant dire la crème de la crème
du barreau c'est le fruit du hasard ou
cette sonorité affichée est délibérée
revendiqué autrement dit c'est un parti
pris
alors peut-être qu'aujourd'hui on le
revendique mais je suis pas du tout sûr
que ce soit construit comme ça mais
peut-être aussi c'est une histoire
d'amitié très forte et on s'est retrouvé
effectivement autour de l'éloquence
autour des combats de ce concours de la
Conférence du stage qu'on a gagné
ensemble et ensuite
on s'est associé avec toutes ces valeurs
là je suis pas sûr d'aimer
peut-être c'est tous ces combats qui qui
nous qui nous forment et qui nous sont
communs et aujourd'hui on se pose la
question donc si est-ce que c'est parce
qu'on est des femmes que c'est combats
sont communs je suis pas sûr mais c'est
peut-être joli de le dire je lisais la
limite et François Scotta ont été des
mentors pour vous absolument de femmes
ça fait plaisir vraiment de les voir de
les voir côte à côte oui des mentors
alors Gisèle Halimi je me souviens
d'avoir lu un livre j'étais vraiment
jeune Jamila boopacha
qui était militante au moment une guerre
d'Algérie que Gisèle avait défendu et
quand je suis devenu avocate bien sûr
c'était d'ailleurs la seule image de
femme la figure de themi tout à fait il
y avait qu'elle et je ne lui avais écrit
un CV de CV 3 c'est pas moi un nombre de
lettres pas possibles et puis j'ai fini
par faire ma carrière par m'installer et
puis un jour c'est elle qui m'a appelé
pour travailler avec elle et pour
partager des dossiers donc ça a été
vraiment
un moment des moments partagés
formidable parce que c'était une grande
intellectuelle c'est une grande penseuse
qu'on a pas toujours nécessairement chez
les avocats on est des travailleurs des
militants quelque chose avec du corps
peut-être moins avec avec l'intellect et
ça a été vraiment une rencontre
magnifique qui ensuite Françoise cotta
que j'ai rencontré ou moi dans ma vie
plus jeune j'étais prof de tennis aussi
je me voyais bien soulever la coupe à
Roland-Garros et quand j'ai entendu
plaider Françoise à la cour d'assise je
me suis dit c'est mon endroit et ça ça a
été une bascule vraiment dans ma vie
vous le disiez la cause des femmes est
devenue un combat à part entière de
votre cabinet même comme vous le
précisez vous assistez toujours les
victimes comme les coupables aussi bien
un ex patron accusé de viol que des
femmes qui incriminent Georges tronc
Jean-Jacques Bourdin ou encore PPDA dans
ces deux dernières affaires vous faites
face à la pénaliste Jacqueline Lafont
sur laquelle vous ne tarissez pas des
Loges c'est pour le moins faire plein
d'autres pas en quoi avoir une
adversaire de cette qualité est une
chance en fait quand on a un très bon
avocat en face c'est une chance parce
que le débat est élevé il y a pas il y a
pas de coup bas
il y a pas d'insultes il y a du respect
mutuel alors bien sûr on va s'affronter
c'est possible aussi que à la sortie de
la salle d'audience on met quand même
quelques semaines à pouvoir se reparler
parce que ça peut ça peut être violent
la violence du débat est là mais la
violence parfois dans le débat
judiciaire en tout cas elle reste avec
un respect mutuel qui est très fort et
j'ai beaucoup de respect c'est sûr pour
le travail qui accompli Jacqueline même
si si vous voulez
pour une partie pour une plaignante
d'entendre un avocat en face c'est
forcément une violence donc les
plaignantes que j'assiste ne puisse pas
supporter Jacqueline à fond c'est
quelque chose que je comprends
absolument mais je crois que ça reste
véritablement une chance par rapport à
parfois des confrères qui sont dans
quelque chose qui est plus personnel si
vous voulez qui s'écarte de la loi l'une
des accusatrices de PPDA la journaliste
Hélène Devinck affirme avoir collecté
plus de 90 témoignages contre l'ex star
du 20h la plupart des faits résumés
semblent aujourd'hui prescrits ça se
plainte dont 8 pour viol ont été déposés
et classées sans suite mais une nouvelle
information judiciaire est en cours à
Nanterre cette fois les juges pourraient
analysés ces accusations dans leur
ensemble et non plus de manière isolée
en quoi cette nouvelle approche pourrait
changer radicalement la donne
je suis pas sûr que on en soit quand
même à ce que ça change radicalement la
donne ce qui est réexaminé c'est
vraiment le cas de Madame Portel qui
elle a un viol non prescrit et un viol
prescrit et c'est dans cet ensemble là
pour ceux qui la concerne elle que les
choses sont seront revues ensuite pour
le moment les plaignantes qui sont
prescrites le demeure et c'est vrai
qu'il y a quelque chose d'assez violent
d'être le témoin de son propre viol et
en même temps il y a aussi quelque chose
de très beau à venir se dire je vais
quand même devant la justice je suis
prescrite mais je viens raconter mon
histoire et dire ce qui s'était avec ce
qui est arrivé mais pour l'instant la
prescription à St acquise alors la
pénaliste Marie dosée comme
l'historienne Elisabeth Badinter
s'inquiète de ces prescriptions de plus
en plus glissantes qui reviendrait
finalement à assimiler des crimes
individuels un crime contre l'humanité
bref aller mettre sur le même plan c'est
là où vous avez une une dissonance ou en
tout cas une dissension avec hé 5 c'est
que vous vous tenez à la prescription
moi je tiens au maintien de la maintien
de la prescription voilà je pense que
c'est pas un crime qui doit être un
prescriptible nous avons un crime
impressionnant
contre l'humanité
je suis super inquiète moi de la dérive
de la loi c'est peut-être la dissonance
que j'ai avec Marie dosée c'est que je
suis pas je pense que la loi
actuellement c'est une bonne loi mais
qu'on doit pas aller plus loin et
effectivement nous avons un crime qui
est un crime de masse qui est un crime
collectif qui englobe le viol d'ailleurs
moi je défends des plaignantes Tutsi
donc qui ont été victimes de viol mais
dans le cadre du génocide entre les
Tutsi et donc à ce moment-là le crime
est reconnu le crime de viol est reconnu
comme un crime contre l'humanité et il
est une arme de guerre et je crois que
on doit rester comme ça c'est aussi la
peste sociale et nous avons certaines
plaignantes qui vivent comme un
soulagement le que la prescription soit
acquise et je crois que faut l'entendre
aussi au micro de France Inter ils
habitent ben inter c'est aussi inquiété
que l'on jette à la maindique publique
un homme en l'occurrence Julien Bayou
vous savez accusé à son ex-compagne de
violence psychologique sans passer par
la justice écoute là où on est
maintenant où sommes-nous
pour mépriser à ce point la justice je
suis parfaitement en accord avec le
ministre de la Justice et ses
déclarations d'hier on peut pas à ce
point mépriser les principes démocrates
Eric Dupond-Moretti a dit il est temps
de siffler la fin de la récréation c'est
extraordinairement dangereux ce qui est
en train de se passer certains se font
dévorer par un monstre qu'ils ont
contribué à créer les réseaux sociaux ne
peuvent pas être l'unique réceptacle
sans filtre de cette parole l'injustice
doit intervenir et encore ce matin nous
allons arriver vers une société de la
délation madame Rousseau n'est pas
procureur général de la nation voilà ce
que dit Eric Dupond-Moretti ce que
reproche et je peux le comprendre les
féministes De Mitou à la justice et
raison pour lesquelles elle retourne
d'eau en fait c'est la question de la
prescription quand c'est prescrit et
donc il y a pas de d'enquête policière
et des juges non non moi je c'est la fin
je dirais de la présomption d'innocence
et le travail sérieux et ben on n'est
pas non plus on s'interroger pourquoi on
porterait pas plainte avant la
prescription enfin je veux dire et ah
ben il pouvait pas les femmes se taisent
c'est tout pardon parfois les femmes se
taisent aussi prendre ses
responsabilités je comprends très bien
que pendant un certain temps même des
années ça soit impossible à évoquer mais
quand même 10 ans
je vois sourire
le sourire c'est un peu un rang parfait
à la violence aussi vous voyez
quelle violence là chez chez Elisabeth
berninter
mais que répondez-vous justement à ceux
qui s'inquiètent de l'émergence d'une
société de l'Inquisition au détriment de
l'État de droit non mais si vous voulez
siffler la fin de la récré voilà pour le
coup c'est Eric Dupond-Moretti qui dit
ça qui est dans la cour de récré qui
pense récréatif en fait de se plaindre
d'aviol et d'aller dénoncer un viol donc
bien sûr qu'on soit vigilant que tout
soit pas réglé par les médias que
l'enquête médiatique de supplépa
l'enquête judiciaire mais personne
personne ne souhaite ça d'ailleurs
Hélène Devinck la première chose qu'elle
a faite c'est d'aller dans un
commissariat pour déposer une plainte
quand bien même elle était prescrite
parce que c'est là que le débat
judiciaire ou que l'enquête se fait
ensuite où est la difficulté d'aller
aussi dire les choses sur le plan public
et en l'occurrence dans cette affaire là
c'est Patrick Poivre d'Arvor qui est
venu sur un plateau en disant qu'elle
vienne me le dire les yeux dans les yeux
et c'est ce qu'elles ont été faire les
yeux dans les yeux donc qui est une
vigilance je suis d'accord
qu'on puisse se dire peut-être que
Sandrine Rousseau elle aurait dû prendre
plus de précautions ça appelle des
précautions de venir sur un plateau de
télévision parce qu'on sait que c'est
pas l'endroit
propice favorable enfin c'est pas
normalement ici que ça se passe mais
dans les histoires de révolution
parce qu'il s'agit d'une révolution
quand même des des mentalités il faut
aussi aller parler au plus grand nombre
et quand vous voyez qu'il y a deux ou
trois personnes dans les cours d'assises
qu'on y supprime d'ailleurs les jurés
que donc il y a plus d'ouverture au
public mais peut-être qu'il faut aller
parler aux gens il y a eu un sondage il
y a quelques temps dans Le Parisien qui
disait que 70% des Français pensaient
quand une femme avait été violée c'est
quand même elle avait pas voulu
l'empêcher donc si on en est encore là
il faut bien que les femmes à éparlaient
sur les plateaux avec des précautions
avec des précautions certains jugent que
le délai de prescription loin de
favoriser l'impunité peu au contraire
servir de déclencheur est-ce que vous
considérez comme elizabether que 20 ans
30 ans c'est suffisant et qu'il faut
qu'elle prenne leur responsabilité le
terme prendre ses responsabilités et
j'ai une violence inouïe inouïe enfin
alors on parle beaucoup de mémoire
traumatique et du fait que les souvenirs
ont été enfouis et puis qui reviennent
alors c'est contesté mais bon parfois
voilà
bon la musique traumatique et c'est
certainement contesté parce que d'un
seul coup sont devenus des mots-valises
et qui fait que nous aujourd'hui on lit
des plaintes où on dit d'ailleurs les
mots sont presque volés au plaignantes
qui se raccrochent à ses concepts là et
en même temps mais il a peut-être fallu
ses mots aussi pour que certaines
comprennent ce qui leur est arrivé ça
fait pas longtemps qu'on sait ce que
c'est qu'un viol
et qu'il décrite et qu'il est du viol
finalement répréhensible et qu'il est
pénalement répréhensible voilà donc il
faut parler à tous les endroits et
comprendre que qu'on peut mettre des
années je crois qu'aujourd'hui les
femmes sont bien mieux accueillies dans
les commissariat et qu'on sait que
parfois et ben on peut déposer plainte
le lendemain 6 mois après ou quelques
années après mais alors précisément
porter plainte 30 ou 40 ans après est-ce
que c'est pas prendre le risque de
l'arbitraire c'est prendre de toute
façon le risque d'une impunité qu'on
recherche c'est le risque de
l'impossibilité de la justice et je
crois que c'est pour cette raison là
aussi que
l'impression
n'aurait pas de sens pour personne mais
mais aussi pour celui qui est accusé et
je pense que tout le monde peut
l'entendre quand on termine de devoir
citoyen même pour quelqu'un qui a été
fracassé par par un crime enfin
peut-être qu'il faut pas demander
d'ailleurs aux gens qui ont été
fracassés par des crimes justement ils
sont pas juges ils sont pas témoins ils
sont pas législateurs et que quand on
est victime on peut pas demander de
d'avoir cette considération pour pour le
citoyen auteur qui est que 30 ans après
un crime les gens changent je crois
qu'on peut pas être avocat on sait que
les gens changent se réhabilitent et
c'est ça l'esprit de la loi aussi et
qu'ensuite la justice n'a plus de sens
lorsqu'elle passe des années après alors
est-ce que ça a du sens de poursuivre
quelqu'un comme PPDA 30 ans après les
faits alors on n'est pas 30 ans pour
pour tout le monde puis tout le monde
est justement n'est pas presque on est
après une telle série
d'impunité pour les plaignantes que
j'assiste et qui elles sont prescrites
les choses sont dites il y a pas de
poursuite judiciaire vous voyez donc moi
je suis pas là pour vous dire si ça a du
sens je pense que que les choses soient
dites oui ça sérieusement du sens les
victimes elles jugent souvent que que le
lynchage médiatique ou ses condamnations
sociales sont propres ni cadre sont
légitimes faute d'une justice
performante et efficiente
je sais pas si c'est légitime faute de
mais en tout cas si la justice était
performante on n'aurait pas besoin de ça
on n'aurait pas besoin de la
Tappellation publique mais oui et c'est
sûr que ça arrive dans ça arrive dans
certains dossiers de voir que la justice
avance pas et que s'il est plaignantes
ou les plaignants parfois sont des
hommes qui sont victimes plus rarement
mais parfois aussi de violence sexuelle
d'après moi il le disent moins aussi
enfin c'est une libération qui pourrait
venir les toucher aussi et ben Vous
déposez une plainte alors formidable
vous êtes mieux reçu là en ce moment et
puis on vous dit ben rappelez-moi dans
18 mois je pense que là je pourrais
commencer l'enquête quoi et alors là
bien sûr que si vous appelez Mediapart
si vous appelez le monde si vous appelez
le Parisien belle enquête elle est faite
beaucoup plus rapidement et puis là les
services de police peut-être un peu m'en
sortir le reproche la honte se mobilise
et vont travailler de leur côté ça
devrait pas se passer comme ça ou même
vous le disiez vous vous défendez des
victimes comme des coupables
vous défendez d'ailleurs dans la presse
Jacques Boutier qui a été l'expdg d'assu
2000 et qui a été incarcéré pour
violation sexuelle notamment quelle
différence y a-t-il entre le traitement
de cette affaire et la mise au pilori
d'un PPDA parce que l'un est mise en
examen à l'autre pas mais en réalité
tous les deux sont présumés innocents
jusqu'à preuve du contraire
oui alors médiatiquement c'est vrai que
la présomption d'innocence est largement
bafouée dans les dans les deux dans les
deux affaires oui et puis pas que la
présomption d'innocence le secret de
l'instruction se rappelle de chez le
juge que dans la presse on retrouve ce
qui a été dit et ce qui est en réalité
mais les gens en danger mais les
enquêtes en danger c'est vrai que sur
les sur les affaires en cours moi
j'appelle vraiment à de la vigilance sur
les affaires prescrites comprend que ça
puisse offusquer pas mal de confrères là
j'imagine que s'il y avait été mis était
ici il me dirait que je raconte
n'importe quoi mais je pense que
la libération de la parole est sur les
plateaux médiatiques et plus saines
parce que justement ça ne se passe pas
ça ne se déroule pas sur un terrain
judiciaire ça vaut comme une
condamnation sociale vous le savez bien
parler dans les médias c'est un appel au
lynchage aujourd'hui avec les réseaux
sociaux de fait
il faudra peut-être les différer un peu
plus sur les réseaux sociaux
parce que je crois pas qu'on puisse se
dire on se musait parce qu'il va y avoir
un lynchage derrière bien sûr c'est
prendre un risque
Hélène de vin que je sais que le jour où
il y a eu les bonnes feuilles publiées
dans le monde et ben le site le monde
c'est quand même pas n'importe quel site
a dû fermer parce qu'il y avait
justement un lynchage alors que
elle-même qu'elle est juste victime quoi
alors un lynchage à l'encontre des
victimes mais aussi à lynchage à l'encon
des mises en cause oui oui bien sûr des
deux tout devient d'une violence inouïe
bon c'est quand même pas cette violence
qui va nous faire taire faudrait-il
interdire de révéler publiquement
l'identité d'une personne accusée d'un
délit sexuel avant toute mise en examen
c'est pas une question que je me suis
posée c'est vrai que je me pose pas
forcément la question de la législation
est-ce que vous seriez pour
pourquoi pas je crois que je peux pas
vous répondre là comme ça réinviter moi
chaque fois je vais répondre à ça mais
je comprends bien moi que
c'est sûr que les gens peuvent pas
répondre voilà il faut quand même être
honnête quand je vous dis je pense
normalement qu'on puisse non pas accuser
mais venir donner son propre récit quand
on est victime mais de fait aussi savoir
que en face ils peuvent pas répondre et
donc c'est en cela qu'il faut appeler à
la mesure que c'est le travail de tout
le monde de votre comme le mien dans son
récit impunité Hélène de Vinc
dénonce l'immunité si je veux dire de
PDA l'inaction de TF1 et la machinerie
qui a trop longtemps poussé les victimes
à se taire cette affaire finalement est
elle aussi une guerre de récit avec en
filigrane la mise en cause d'un système
et d'un milieu
alors la justice c'est le récit c'est
vraiment
ça n'a rien à voir avec la vérité
d'ailleurs ça s'appelle la vérité
judiciaire mais comme on a la vérité
historique la vérité scientifique
[Musique]
PPDA c'est pas que l'histoire de viol au
pluriel c'est effectivement je pense que
le titre est magnifiquement trouvé
l'histoire d'une impunité quand on sait
qu'il a fait une fausse interview par
exemple et on se dit qu'il est final
gastro voilà il continue de présenter le
journal de 20H derrière quand on sait
qu'il y a eu un plagié à tout ça est
reconnu je veux dire donc on peut parler
tranquillement il y a eu un plagiat sur
un livre et qui continue de présenter
des émissions littéraires je veux dire
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire de plus grave
j'imagine quand on est journaliste que
de truquer ininterview quand on est
écrivain que de commettre un plagiat pas
écrire ses livres et donc ça pose la
question de de l'idole ça pose la
question de du mythe que je trouve
formidable d'ailleurs comme comme
question et de pourquoi on déboulonnent
pas de toutes cette machinerie et qui
vous empêche de parler et de cette
banalisation aussi d'une impunité qui
fait que tout le monde reste finalement
bouche bée PPDA a décidé de porter
plainte pour dénonciation qu'elle
aimeuse cette stratégie de défense
cette stratégie de défense a été perçue
par les pouillantes comme une mesure de
représailles parce que tout simplement
défendre coup de chair vous vous allez
qualifier cette plante par un mot un
seul une claque
oui oui parce que une claque et puis
après
ça nous a fait rire parce que ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est très
important dans la vie quand même
une claque parce que c'est une inversion
de une inversion de la violence et en
même temps ensuite ça fait rire et puis
ça fait dire ben allons-y à ce procès
que finalement nous on n'arrive pas à
avoir puisque nous nous sommes prescrits
justement c'est une opportunité c'est
une opporte la parole de ces
accusatrices comme du mise en cause se
déploie dans l'arène judiciaire vraiment
on l'attend avec grand plaisir et alors
je n'ai pu voir que quelques extraits de
cette plainte parce que finalement quand
on dépose plein de contre vous ne savez
qu'au moment où vous êtes convoqué et
vraiment mais les extraits puisque vous
voyez c'est dans les médias que j'ai pu
les lire que j'ai lu sont absolument
savoureux j'ai su que l'adversaire voyez
était pas l'avocate habituel de PPDA
parce que c'était insultant en fait ce
qui ce qui était ce qui était écrit dans
les médias donc j'ai un peu hâte qu'on
puisse lire la plainte et qu'on puisse y
répondre on l'attend de pied ferme et
les yeux dans les yeux s'ils nous
regarderait la justice vous ignore on
ignore la justice on se souvient tous de
la charge d'Adèle à NL dans Mediapart la
comédienne est loin d'être la seule à
penser que la justice ne sert à rien
sinon elle est dissuader de porter
plainte vous partagez ce constat oui
alors moi j'avais écrit un article après
ou je l'avais qu'elle était titrée à
delenelle virgule trop bien pour la
justice point d'interrogation parce que
c'est vrai que c'est c'est une vraie
question et et elle a bien fait parce
que c'est elle qui a quand même été le
déclencheur de cette question là en me
disant mais en fait
moi si j'y vais je vais être mal reçu et
puis il va rien se passer donc
parce que c'est très personnel parce
qu'il vous avait déjà été déposé
de quelque chose d'une intimité de
quelque chose d'inouïe vous avez déjà eu
une effraction terrible moi j'incite pas
à la deuxième violence en fait bien sûr
sur sur un devoir citoyen quand je suis
en face de quelqu'un j'ai envie de lui
dire mais si il faut y aller c'est comme
ça qu'on va améliorer les choses et
c'est comme ça qu'on va aller porter le
discours mais on peut aussi avoir envie
de se taire et on peut avoir on peut
penser que ça reconstruction elle passe
par autre chose la reine judiciaire
est-ce que pour mieux prendre en compte
les plaignantes ne devrait-on pas
clarifier la notion de consentement la
redéfinir la repenser dans notre droit
beaucoup de pays l'Espagne le Canada la
Suède l'ont fait et vous savez que la
sociologue Irène Terry a proposé de
faire entrer dans notre droit la notion
de crédit de véracité qui permette aux
personnes qui dénoncent les violences
sexuelles de ne plus être soupçonné de
mentir jusqu'à preuve du contraire
[Rires]
un acte de pénétration sexuelle avec
menace violence contrainte ou surprise
et en fait ça fait peser la charge
uniquement sur l'acte et pas sur la
victime qui n'a pas à dire j'ai été
consentante en réalité c'est un
dévoiement à mon sens de la loi que de
parler de consentement et plus on va
aller parler de consentement plus
effectivement ça va faire peser sur la
plaignante le fait d'aborder madame
alors est-ce que vous avez dit que vous
étiez pas d'accord madame elle a pas à
dire qu'elle était pas d'accord et vous
portez plainte pour parce qu'on a volé
votre sac personne ne met votre parole
en doute pourquoi est-ce que quand vous
portez plainte pour viol ah ben ça c'est
une vraie question je suis complètement
d'accord avec vous d'acheter votre mais
à mon sens pas à cause de la loi parce
que la loi normalement ne doit pas se
poser la question du côté de la victime
alors elle est elle est géniale cette
question parce que pourquoi
mais je passe mon temps à expliquer ça
et
j'en veux un peu au contraire quand ils
le font pas vous intervenants quand ils
le font parce que on peut avoir envie de
faire plaisir et de dire vous allez voir
avec la justice ça va vous apporter
telle chose c'est une pierre
certainement et c'est encore une fois
c'est pas une pierre pour tout le monde
mais c'est vrai qu'on voit aussi des
scènes judiciaires qui sont magnifiques
qui font que pour tous ces jours où on
est découragé il y a aussi ces jours où
ça arrivent ces moments où merci Maître
quoi ça a été vraiment un moment
un moment clé et essentiel mais pas que
d'en porter leur voix
merveilleux livre vous racontiez votre
quotidien au parloir des prisons dans
les prétoirs dans le bureau des juges à
votre cabinet vous racontiez des
histoires de coupables de victimes des
histoires humaines et dès la première
phrase je vous cite il en va du Palais
de justice de Paris comme de certains
hommes l'extérieur est splendide
l'intérieur est pourri le ton est donné
[Musique]
la justice est violente mais disons-le
disons-le d'entrée et il y a un rapport
aussi de violence extrême entre les
avocats et les magistrats ce qui ce qui
jugent et ceux qui défendent ce qui
accuse et ceux qui défendent il y a des
places que on aurait choisi pour rien au
monde dans la vie il y a des places
auxquelles on se sent bien et auxquelles
on est assigné et il y a des hommes oui
dans ton on peut se dire qu'il y a
quelque chose de pourri au royaume des
Danemark comme des certains mais qui a
la Lumière que vous placez à un autre
endroit et c'est pour ça que on ment pas
parce que nous on parle de ces endroits
là
merci Varic merci d'Aster Olivier